my name is Gocha converse kya work
football from research as a developer
I'm going to talk about time serious
processing which is kind of the same
title as the talk as I gave last year at
the conference and so somehow some
things are the same some things are new
and I'm not going to assume that
everybody was here last year and knows
everything what was covered last year so
i'm going to start from some basic
definition feel free to ask me questions
that may need a bit of magnification
okay so we basically have three data
structures data objects in Mathematica
Wolfram language that are designed to
store our temporarily over their data
which is the time serious event serious
and temporal data and they they have a
live in design with certain you know
specific goal in mind and so the time
series is designed to store single path
objects we assume kind of that the data
is continues event series we assume that
what we store it's discreet so this
interpolation between the values does
not make sense and temporal data is the
one to rule them all and I can store
multiple multiple data of any of either
of the other types there are no
assumptions made on this so to start
examples so the creation so we if the
time series give the values and then if
you give automatic it's going to
automatically design a feed the stumps
the x times and we start automatically
at zero so this is our initial count
it's going from zero this is how to
create a very basic event series and
this is to create the temporal data all
of these objects of their own type
setting when you click on the plus here
it's going to give you more information
for example about the dimensionality of
the data and also about the the
interpolation weather
you can see here that we have any
relation or in this case of the event
series this is non-existent over there
the main difference here that you see
between the time series event series and
temporal data is what we get when we
evaluate the object at the given time
stamp so for time series and event
series we actually get the value that
happen to be corresponding to the given
time stamps and for the temporal data we
get the data distribution because as I
said this object was designed to store
multipath so we were interested in
actually the sliced distribution from
this data then if I asked for the what
is the value between the timestamps see
the diatoms terms were integers so I
asked for the for the value at half the
time series gives us interpolated value
event serious tells you that's not gonna
you know be there it's just missing
value and then temporal data gives us
the the data distribution that comes
from the interpolation so this is an
example where the temporal data really
comes as a storage is when we simulate
the random processes so this is a random
function for the Venera process on the
on the interval from 0 to 1 and what I
have this 10 to the 4 is the number of
the sampling paths so what we can work
what we can do here for example is to
ask for the histogram of the slice of
the data at health and also for the CDF
at the same in time timestamp and this
is the longest evaluation in on my talk
so and here we go so that's that's why
this this data distribution is therefore
this multiple objects properties so
properties can be accessed by the
property very convenient so you can see
that the the time series properties and
event series properties are almost
identical there is one thing that is
different which is the path function
that exists for the time series but not
for the tile for the event series
because of this interpolation that we
don't have
the event series and by default in the
tire in a time series we interpolate
with interpolation order one and this
can be seen right when you when you only
open here there is a way to change that
and this is the this is this can be done
via the option to the sampling method
and so the TS one will be the new time
series what I change the interpolation
order to two or I can you know said the
missing values and we not the missing
but the values in between the stumps to
something else like a constant say zero
and then the path function here for the
for this gives us the order to of
interpolation and here where we set this
value to be to be constant we just get a
plane a plane piecewise function and
then for the for the temporal data the
properties but they will include the
parula floors so basically I can have
the the if I give the path I want to
have the first path if I give pops I'm
going to get all of them so they're just
mirroring okay arithmetic on the time
series it's the new feature that it's
it's coming now I think it's the 10.2
matemática so what we would like to do
is to directly add the time series
objects and the first case is the very
simple one is when we have identical
time stamps so TS want is to you see
different values but because I give the
automatic time stamps there all the time
goes from zero to three and then adding
them is clear and straight ok I'm just
going to add the values on the existing
time stamps because they much the
problem is ok I have the time stamps
that are not matching so I create the
new time series that here is this is our
way to provide explicitly the list of
the time stamps so this double list
gives you gives you the time some some
some adding some house here and the
the result here it is a time series
object we can we can do this but you see
that the time is from 0 to 3 halves and
so what happen is that we are looking at
the new timestamps and so I plot those
see that the new that is that the some
kind of is the same short as the tea is
free so what happens is that we we
created the new time series which is on
the union of the time stamps which lie
within the intersection of the intervals
coming from the to time series because
that's where those are defined and the
this new time x times the one half and
three over two that were not existent in
our first time series but we
interpolated so the values there are the
interpolated values so this is the times
on the on the t3 this is the values
coming from the ts1 and we basically add
those together and get the result and
then depending on the precision on the
timestamps you're gonna get the same
precision on the new values for the
interpolating between the time stamps
for the event series on the conditions
are much stricter we really don't have
the interpolation so we cannot do the
same the same thing when we don't have
the matching time stamps so marching
time stamps great we're going to end up
with the new event series in the in a
rational way if create the new event
series and try to add those when the
timestamps are not matching it is not
gonna go it just returns unevaluated yes
yes that that's a possible yeah yes and
so but they need to be there so you
cannot create any and a new stamps in
the event series so that's that's the
constraint and when we are dealing with
the with the mixing so adding the time
series to event series the result will
be the stronger ones which is the time
series yes yes but that would be the
different operation so you would want to
kind of three process that yeah yeah so
what you need to we need to kind of make
it to the point when it's going to be
clear what you want with the time stamps
yes but as we as I'm going to move on to
the operations on the time series that
might answer your question also what
would be the write operation to do is oh
sorry event series do not have a
sampling method just don't the other
thing the other ticket you can do you
can you can you can change the subject
to time series so time series on event
series gives you the time series and
then you enjoy all the beautiful
properties of time series that might be
you know so event series it's really you
know the number of deaths that you're
not going to interpolate between the
years right so this type of design of
objects other operations so for example
taking the minimum it's going to take
the minimum and all the values if we
have you know modulo free operation on a
time series gives us the new time series
and also we can shift the whole series
and here i would like to say that this
shifting means that we are adding this
free to the values so we kind of shifted
the whole over use was upended
works in a direct way okay double life
of timestamps so there is nothing new
about this as I would say but the
timestamps that we kind of looked at at
the beginning our integer timestamps and
so we kind of think about the time
stamps as they are ordering our
observations in time but especially when
we start looking at dates and for those
of you who are coming from the previous
talk talk on on a date and calendar
functionality we know the desire the
absolute moments in time so this this
time stamps served in kind of two
purposes that may set us set up in Eden
in space you know it's kind of well not
well versed but put us in the time space
or order and in that sense they they
have this for me double life as we
understand i will show you example in a
moment what I mean so the time series
with dates okay there is one thing that
we know the observations happen on a
given day for example we can look at the
time increments between them okay and
there is a function minimum time
increment tells you that they happened
you know every this is the smallest
difference in time stamps is one day but
also this is a financial data so we know
nothing happens on sundays for example
so this is not really that that i'm
going to have this data here sampled
every single day so um regularly sampled
q tells us that actually that's true
this data is not coming on every single
day and you can see that the differences
between the time stamps at ravari
because they account for the weekends
right this is the business data so this
is this is this is slightly problematic
in the way that we understand the data
coming to us on business days is coming
in on regularly sampled space because
these are the business days and yet as
as we are looking naturally at the
distances of the day this is not
regularly sampled so there at least two
ways to
to deal with this and to teach time
series that this data we want to treat
this data is regularly sampled so why
still use the time series for example
I'll have a list of all the all the
functions working on time since the
moment and the other option is to force
the understanding full of the regularity
with the option so set temporal
regularity to true and so we can check
that they are in this regularly sampled
and also what is more important we
haven't changed the path at all so the
pulse are exactly the same as our
original data all we did is just the
understanding of the steps that we're
looking at this data is coming in our
regular steps and why is this important
is where we want to take it farther to
the processes and actually model with
the time series processes because the
ones that we have in Mathematica are
defined in terms of the discrete unit
time increments so I'm looking at the
steps and I would like them to come in
regular steps to actually fit into the
algorithms that we are working with okay
so when we look at the at the example
here is the random process a our process
the autoregressive the simulation
returns us by default the path which is
indexed by integers so these are my
consecutive observations if i look at
the another process this is the air
process with the x0 as my initial
observation and this is by default
understood as observation happening at
the negative one time and i would like
to calculate the mean for this you see
because this this is not a weekly
stationary process this mean this this
means going to change with every step
where we assume that this this kind of
unit times are the same for each step
and we have two functions that are doing
dealing with the modeling for the time
series processes the time series model
feet and then estimated process so just
make sure we have the same data here
from the financial data it's not
regularly sampled
and if I try to use the time series
model feet on this irregularly sample
data it recognizes that the assumptions
are not met and it's going to do
something about this and in this case
it's gonna resample so it's going to
interpolate on this missing days because
this data it's it's irregular example
doesn't know that it has to come on the
on the business days the problem is that
we are actually looking at the model for
this new temporal data this new time
series you can see it has 92 data points
so what we did was actually to increase
the data and have it more to find a
model I the original data here at 64 an
estimated process which is going to say
I'm not going to do this leap of faith
here and just fail and just returned and
white it and say is that it expecting
the uniformly spaced data so if i take
the one that we are that we adjust that
then we we can find the models using the
time series model feed from the original
data or using using the estimated
process okay so to modify the values and
times of the over existing time series
we have a suite of functions I this is
this is the least of all of them most of
them start with time series and then
what would you like to do with this with
the exception of the moving map so i
called it the lounge released and I'm
gonna go fairly quickly through those
are part 1 will deal with easy numeric
examples / to Utley more abstract so
this is the same time series that I just
repeat so we we saw that a sampling okay
so Rosanna sample just gives you the
dieter upsampling or down something
selecting some values from the existing
or you want to create more by
interpolation time series shift this is
moving the the times so you see that we
had original x 2 4 6 now we have three
five seven so the time series shift
would allow us to adjust the timestamps
window is where we can select
some value so the window it's from three
to six so I'm going to have the two
observations only in this the window
time series insert that here 1 comma 2.8
it means I would like to put the value
to point and on the timestamp one okay
so this is my new time series and then I
can also do the same with not just a
single of time value pair but also the
new time series so that would be I think
question from Peter how to intertwine to
event series yes so this you can stack
one into into another yes rescale this
is a situation where we would like to
really change the time stamps and so in
these situations i have x times 2 46
what I would like to do is to now change
them into dates so from today in the
plus three more days and so the
important something important to note
here is that the first normal on this
time series gives us the data objects in
the time stamps and then if I take the
second normal then it's going to go down
to the date list so part two these are
the more insane more may be more complex
operations so x 3 is map maps over the
values so this is this is for example
difference between taking the maximum of
the of the just time series okay that
will give us the max of all the values
collectively okay but if i have here
time series which has the values which
are two dimensionals i would use time
series map to actually take the
operation on each value independently so
that's where we still need the time
series map even though there are many
operations that work directly on the
only time series the time serious threat
is to combine two series so we can just
you know total or any other function
that would work on the on the values
from that from the both
time series and the map fred is working
on both the x and the values from the
given time series so here i am just
having the values being raised to the
power which is a timestamp in this thing
then we have a time series aggregate
which is going to apply a given function
over the window so my function here is
just for illustration F and I'm applying
over the window of length 2 so I'm
taking two values for each foliage
instance of function with exception of
the last one because it's odd and so
that can be Illustrated for example for
the aggregation over the month you know
and taking the mean so that's going to
be our aggregated monthly mean and you
can see here that the placement of the
windows happens to be in the middle of
each month you can you can read through
the dates okay and the last on the list
was moving map and moving map actually
right now would call it moving map to
point all because it went through the
for the changes for the 10.2 and many
things are new and also when sasha i
mentioned in his talk there is some
incompatibility but small and so i'm
just going to focus on what it's doing
now to to illustrate what we can do with
this so moving map giving the function
and you can give it also at just just
the data and then give the window length
so this this last argument here is the
window of window length and so you can
see that actually f is going to take
three arguments in it because it's
looking at the window of length 2 if you
want to specify the number of of
arguments that that would be equivalent
to say quantity free events of this this
works for the irregular a spy
data and because it's regularly spaced
and we're looking at the window of
length tool sometimes we're going to
have one element sometimes two elements
depending how how they are positions in
the in the time series and by default
the window is placed on the right and
this is a just comparison where we place
the window on the left center on the
right so we can see how this is moving
and also how the number of arguments in
the function is changing and when we
decide to give quantity of free events
which means fix the number of elements
then it does the position really doesn't
change the number of arguments that come
into the function so that was the
function was taking the values what we
can also do now is to give different
arguments of the function doesn't have
to be only the values but so repeating
our example this is the values we can
actually also operate on x so the
function on the times from each window
we can use boundary times and also
notice that some of these boundary times
are not the existing timestamps in the
time series so it's looking at the I'm
still talking about the window of length
2 so it has to have the boundaries of
the window and this not necessarily has
to coincide with the existing timestamps
and you can see this definitely when we
look here at the boundary values because
those will be interpolated for the
looking at the values that actually are
not existing in a time series we can
place the windows in the result and and
what we want to really give a range of
the timestamps and so on this is for the
for the for the events and for the data
time serious this is me more interesting
example oops sorry excuse me I just
saved my time series in case I lost a
connection here but this is the finance
she'll data of of starbucks and looking
at the at the moving map of the mean and
you see that maybe I should show you the
path here okay that's not good right
because we cannot really say what it is
but what we can now do is the date path
and we can get dates instead of the
absolute times so they are there the
windows are placed on different days
yeah I can decide and I would like to
have them at the end of each week and
say place on Saturdays so this is just a
little calculation to find how many
Saturday so we'll have within my data
and then this is the this is the coal
moving map mean and then i have it on
the right on those dates okay so this is
this is the the date path for for the
moving map and so what happens is that
we actually did very similar job to what
the time series aggregate would do
because the windows that i that i
created our own saturday said the length
five so they're not going to be
overlapping so we created we are going
to recreate the job of the time series
aggregate with the with the addition
that we placed our windows where you
want and so when we compare this now to
the time series aggregate you see this
is the path of the time series aggregate
for this data it's on mondays but when
you look at this the values are the same
but they are just placed on a different
days so the moving map it's becoming
very flexible into into basically give
us the the give us the freedom to place
the resulting timestamps where we want
and also one more thing for the moving
map is that we can specify padding so
that's our example time series and the
partying just makes sense when we talk
about the window length because if you
give the number of elements that's
clearly you just want this minor
elements so this is what you get the
error message
where you try to apply padding with the
of the events so don't be scared okay if
we take the specification here for the
for the for the length of the window and
we say none that means that i'm going to
take all the windows and you can see
that the number of elements in my
function f it varies automatic partying
means that it's gonna taking the windows
that will have exactly the length free
there and then here this is the padding
that has 22 input so the automatic
padding for x and then the constant p
for the values so you can see here that
the where the p appears we had the
padded value and then it found
automatically what would be the right
time to to put it to put it into the
time series ok i almost out of time so i
just want to quickly mention that
there's also support in the filtering
functions for time series and what is
fairly new is the support for the
irregularity a sample time series and so
I'm gonna start here that we can have
this is to just convince you that it's
not regularly sampled it has some crazy
minimum time increment and then point2
will be our neighborhood where we look
at the mean filter and then in this
sense by default will correspond to the
to the quantity going to second so that
also point out that the filters work of
the quantities and we can also use
filters on the time series with dates
and so this is the the median filter
with the quantity of five days and just
to plot this
so thank you this is my email if a
Nevada has more questions and of course
how will be happy to answer questions